هذا هو الجينز النيلي الحقيقي النيلي
مات هناك من مادة كيميائية ولكن النيلي الحقيقي
مباشرة من النبات له جذوره في
ثقافة الساموراي وهو ذو قيمة عالية
في اليابان.
]
تقع منطقة توكوشيما اليابانية في
الجنوب الغربي من البلاد ،
وقد اشتهرت لعدة قرون
بنهرها بسبب نهر يوشينوجاوا
الذي يتدفق تحت الأرض مما يؤدي إلى ارتفاع درجة حرارة التربة ، وقد
بدأ نيلي في اكتساب شعبية في
أوائل القرن السابع عشر ، وكان يستخدمه
الساموراي
سوتو بشكل شائع.  فعل هذا الشيء الصغير
الذي أخبرتك به يا لونا لكنها حصلت على قبلة حقيقية ،
هذه ركبة أوسامو ،
إنه من الجيل السادس من مزارع نبات النيلي
مذهل تمامًا ، أليس كذلك أنا أعرف
جيمينو ، لذا فأنت تعرف دقائق معه
موشي ، يا رفاق سيحصلون عليهم جميعًا
هنا عرض توضيحي ، هل يمكنني فتح عجلة الملحمة ،
تم استخدام النيلي أيضًا لملابس رجال الإطفاء
لأنه مثبط للهب يصل
إلى 1500 درجة فهرنهايت
لإنتاج حبر نيلي ، يجب
حصاد الأوراق وحصادها  جفت الدجاجة في الشمس
وانقلبت مرارًا وتكرارًا بالمكنسة
حتى تتحول إلى لون بحري ، لقد انتظرت في
دائرة رقيقة لإرسالنا إلى هناك لأن
Osamu هو واحد من آخر 5
مزارعين جدد في المنطقة ، هذه الممارسة هي
الوقت-  مستهلك ويتطلب جهدًا كثيفًا ، لذا
تحول المزارعون السابقون إلى
بدائل كيميائية أرخص ولكن الشيء
الذي يمكنك الحصول عليه باللون النيلي الحقيقي
لا مثيل له ،
هذا هو Toshi haru furusho ، إنه
إطار من القماش يايا ،
لذا فأنا أعطي كعكات للمشي في الخارج
طوال اليوم بعض الاهتمام  يا له من خطأ
تعرفه وأنا أعلم أنه قادر على سحب
مجموعة مذهلة من البلوز من
الحبر الطبيعي من أزرق أسود تقريبًا
أطلقوا عليه اسم سهم نانو إلى أعماق المحيطات التي
يطلق عليها هيوز Cacharel وهو
يحقق هذه الألوان على الرغم من أنه ليس
بالأمر السهل ولا أحتاج  كسر الكاكاو حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، يمكن رؤية التزامه بمهنته
في يديه ،
وأظافره ملطخة باللون الأزرق إلى الأبد من ما يقرب من 50
عامًا من العمل مع الموت غدًا ،
لقد كنت أتساءل ماذا تفعل
افتقدني أسامة ، إنه لم يعلق
محاكمته بعد ، إما نعم يا صديقي إسحاق
أوريو
سوزوكا ، أعتقد أن OTO الذي يعرف الشاب goken no
ice under kimochi جيد أنت تعرف نعم
مرحبًا بالرقم الذي كتبه Tetsu لك Chikara يستأنفك
[موسيقى]